it can be very useful when you're
approaching a work like Rousseau's
discourse on the origins of inequality
among human beings to take kind of a
big-picture overview of it before
concentrating on each of the parts and
what I want to do here goes beyond just
talking about key ideas or genre or
historical context as I did in the
previous video what I want to do here is
give you what we might call the master
argument of Rousseau's discourse tell
you where it's beginning where it's
ending up what he wants to get you the
reader to to consider to accept to to
buy into by the yeah and it's quite a
fascinating and enigmatic work
oftentimes students when they're
approaching it and I I myself did this
the first couple times that I read it
you're asking yourself what is actually
going on here is this supposed to be
history or anthropology or political
philosophy or pure speculation I'm not
quite sure about what he's trying to do
or the points that he's trying to make
he's hard to pin down he's it's very
clear what he's criticizing it's not
always quite as clear what he is arguing
for and so what I want to do is give you
the panorama picture of what's going on
you notice that we're going to talk
about three main we could call them
states or conditions when we talk about
the human condition or so as somebody
who is willing to say there is something
that we can call the general human
condition because we're all really at
bottom the same kind of animals but
whether we're in civilization or what
type of civilization or degree of
civilization we're in plays an
incredibly important role for him in the
condition that we live in so we have
what he calls the original state of
human beings and then there's some
transitions that are happening and he's
concern to try to show us how
these transitions might have taken place
in part by talking about human nature
and what had to happen in order for
human nature to go in this way and to
develop and to be realized and then we
reached what we can call a state of
savagery a state that Rousseau thought
correspond to many of the indigenous
peoples that the Europeans were
encountering Rousseau didn't have any
first-hand experience with this he's
relying on reports from from travelers
and from people who are colonists or
explorers living among the Native
Americans in the you know what's now the
Americas or peoples in far-off other
places that are rather exotic but he can
also think of this in terms of some of
the historical developments that were
aware of these these great tribal
peoples that eventually become you know
nations that become more and more
civilized and finally we have a state of
civilization which is an ongoing process
it's possible to become more and more
and more civilized it's not like you
snap your fingers and now you're in
civilization
it's a gradual continuing process and in
many respects this is a story of decline
and fall from our original pretty happy
human condition in the state of nature
where we although you know we were happy
we didn't really realize that we're
happy or why we were happy or anything
like that because we hadn't developed
much where it's still in the realm of
the animals just slightly different in
some very important respects from from
the other animals from there we develop
more and more techniques more and more
technologies more and more things that
gradually transform not only our
environment not only produce a society
but transform the human being create new
possibilities for them to feel different
passions for example we'll talk about
that in a moment
and things become more and more
complicated
and they get worse and worse and worse
according to her so in the process so
for Rousseau the ongoing progress of
civilization is not actually a progress
towards greater and greater and greater
good the way that many other people in
his own time saw it he's gonna say it's
a it's a mixed blessing now why is he
writing this in the first place
it's about inequality it's it's a
discourse on the origins of inequality
but it's not just about origins it's
also about inequality in the present and
if we think about what is inequality
we're gonna spend an entire video just
talking about his discussions of the
development of various modes of
inequality but what is it to be unequal
Rousseau makes a distinction a very
important distinction really on where he
talks about physical inequality I am you
know six-foot-three I'm not in
particularly good shape so probably most
of the people watching this video I'm
bigger than you I weigh more than you I
may even be stronger than quite a few of
you because although I haven't you know
been an athlete for more than a decade I
was at one time and I still retain some
of that with me but that's a physical
inequality we can also talk about other
people being bigger than me or smaller
than me or stronger than me or faster
than me we can make all sorts of
comparative things along those lines and
I could contrast myself against Mike my
pets you know I'm much bigger than my
cat I'm stronger than my cat although my
cat pound-for-pound is a hell of a lot
stronger than I am although I don't
sleep 16 hours a day some of that
strength comes from from you know having
the kind of muscles that can do short
bursts of activity but you see we're
talking about physical inequality there
that's not the sort of inequality that
Rousseau is really interested in because
physical inequalities can be and have
been largely overcome for human beings
at least by the use of technology and by
the development of
culture so what kind of inequality are
we concerned with you know in our own
situation now inequality is a big
buzzword both in politics and in
economics and a lot of people tend to
think about inequality just in terms of
wealth in terms of how much money you
have so your current possessions your
current wealth your current ownership or
in terms of income you know how much can
you make other people will think about
in terms of opportunities do you have
the opportunity to go to a good college
or you know is are you restricted from
going to the more selective colleges you
know if it's just a matter of your SAT
scores there's probably not a great case
anymore for saying well you you know
you're being dealt with in an unfair
arbitrary way although some people still
make those sort of cases but if somebody
is excluding you in our society on the
basis of your gender or your race or
veteran status or religion we tend to
see those sort of inequalities as ones
that were very concerned with and we
think matter quite a bit now you know in
Rousseau's European society the
inequalities between rich and poor were
much more glaring even than they are
currently today and that plays a role
but there's also you know when we talk
about rich and poor and we talk about
upper class and lower class and middle
class we're talking about something like
a system of layering strata and the
strata correspond to prestige they
correspond to the assumed value of a
person it doesn't have to do with
opportunities as well but much of it
depends on who you get to associate with
where you get to go what people will
assume about you
if you you know language is a something
we're going to talk about language can
give away social class if I speak in a
northern Wisconsin the accent as opposed
to the southeastern Wisconsin
right here which part of the way as far
as linguistics go is is pretty much the
same accent as they have here in the
Hudson Valley in New York except for all
the you know people from the city who
came up who still have New York accents
I am I'm going to be perceived in
different ways the vocabulary that I
choose will will do that as well now
these are all kinds of inequality that
can make a big difference
workplace you know he's been a talk
quite a bit about slavery and about
occupations we might think in terms of
our workplace I for example am an
adjunct I'm not going to get out to a
lot of adjunct issues but adjuncts are
pretreated pretty Shapley compared to
full-time professors in most
institutions there's there's a whole
literature out there that we could go
into I've been fortunate avoided kind of
quite a bit of that but I know many
people who are in terrible conditions of
inequality that's part of what adjuncts
are currently unionism there's a
contemporary example so when we're
thinking about inequality whether we're
in the eighteenth century like Rousseau
was or whether we are in the 21st
century like we are today and whether
we're thinking about in global terms or
in terms of one particular society we
can ask ourselves certain questions that
this discourse is meant to try to answer
the one that Rousseau is going to focus
on the most is how did we actually get
here he is going to try to tell us a
story he's gonna try to reconstruct an
account and the story that he's telling
by the way is one that is supposed to be
better than the stories that other
people have been telling about this this
sort of thing and about human origins
the 18th century and the 17th century
before it had quite a few theorists who
were talking about the state of nature
talking about the origin of property the
origin of laws the origin of civil
society Thomas Hobbes is a great example
poofing Dorf who he talks about Locke
you know Locke is somebody very
important for the American context as
well
they all have theories of the state of
nature and they would eventually talk
about things like a social contract or
you know moving towards civil society
now Rousseau it wants to look at this
picture very carefully and he's going to
place a much greater stress on certain
key developments that are going to take
place and those key developments help to
answer the question how did we get here
so agriculture and metallurgy are part
of the answer to that or the development
of law and government
another key component to that the
development of language that's something
central as well so when we ask this sort
of question how did we get here and we
provide some sort of narrative or story
that is supposed to answer that question
and provide us with a coherent you know
progression from one thing to the next
to the next to the next here we get into
what's really interesting about Russo's
position when we're asking about
present-day
inequality or about the inequalities
that are taking place along the way one
of the things that we can ask about is
whether it's got a necessary basis
whether things have to be this way and
if we're doing this kind of comparative
work where we talk about you know an
original state and that a state of
savagery of uncivilized human beings and
then we talk about a state of
civilization that produces a lot more
Goods and you know a lot a lot of
variety of things but also a lot misery
we can say well it's not actually
necessary that human beings be at this
point because they were at this point
before they were still human beings then
and they could even be back there so
that's one sense of it we can also tell
ourselves in Rousseau's view that these
great developments that he
but along the way they were not actually
necessary
they were contingent and so this
provides what we would call a
genealogical account where we're tracing
things back to origins the genesis of
things and we're showing how where
things currently are in the present is a
product of fortuitous or you know not
deliberate not well planned out but to
some degree contingent and arbitrary
processes that have taken place you know
and to say that some of them are
contingent think about a language for
example it may not be contingent that
human beings developed language perhaps
there's something about the nature of
human beings that did involve us
gradually developing linguistic
capacities and actually developing human
languages but on the English is a great
example for this how we actually spell
things in the English language
totally contingent totally a matter of
an entire history that unless you've
studied the language you're not going to
know very much about you'll just be
puzzled about you know where where and
where or there there and there
or why a swim swam that doesn't seem to
make any sense but if you know the the
history of it you know the genealogy of
it you say oh I'm swam is the the
preterite and Germanic languages have a
preterite and they involve unloading
vowel change now see once you do that
sort of thing you can understand how
things got to where they are but you
realize that although there seems to be
something like a kind of necessity
operating there they didn't really have
to be that way they may be the product
of cause and effect that happened but
it's not some sort of absolutely
necessary in the nature of the universe
sort of thing that dictates that English
spelling or actually French spelling for
that at that matter too is so bizarre
and archaic and difficult and creates
all sorts of problems or for try to
learn English right so that's another
thing - does it have a necessary basis
we're going to explore that and
here's another key question what should
we do here we're asking the question of
what is Russo actually trying to get on
here is he saying that civilization is
is bad and we should try to escape from
civilization and maybe go off to the
South Sea Islands and you know like you
know an artist and just to sort of live
a a savage life or perhaps even try to
get back to this original state of
nature is that a possibility for us or
are we screwed are we just stuck with
civilization with all of its problems
and perhaps we can try to ameliorate
certain things in certain ways you know
reduce some of the inequalities but
perhaps were doomed what is he actually
saying now I do have a good answer to
that that last one available for you
he talks at a certain point and this is
in the first part of the discourse he
says it's easy to see that many of the
differences which distinguished men are
merely the effect of habit and the
different methods of life men adopt in
society a robust or delicate
Constitution and the strength or
weakness attaching to it are more
frequently the effects of a hearty or a
feminine method of education than of the
original endowment of the body it's the
same with the powers of the mind he
continues for education not only makes a
difference between such as are cultured
and such as or not but even increases
the differences which exist among the
former in proportion to their respective
degrees of culture as the distance
between a giant and a dwarf on the same
Road increases with every step that they
take so what what Rousseau is saying
here is that we do as human beings have
some capacity to determine in
civilization in the vantage point that
he's writing from whether we want to
suffer all of the problems and all that
inequalities that come with civilization
the miseries of civilized life or
whether we want to try to return at
least in part to
something that would be less bound by
the laws less in fear of the state and
the government less obsessed with
comparison and with wealth-getting and
all these sorts of things that's why
we're so not only is an Enlightenment
figure but also a romantic figure one of
these sort of in many respects back to
nature kind of types so all of that said
let's now turn to this diagram that I
put up here and since I drew it we may
as well use it right you don't notice
like I said we have the original state
of human beings a state of savagery and
finally succeeding that a state of
civilization and what we're talking
about here are quite literally thousands
of generations of human beings so we're
not talking about an individual jumping
from one to the next although you could
take a person who's in a state of
savagery and perhaps try to you know
make the miserable different
civilization or so I'd say you can
actually say you know a little those
tribal people those indigenous peoples
leave them the hell alone they're doing
okay already you don't need to make them
worse off by introducing all this sort
of stuff now what we're what we're
looking at here is a progress you notice
I've got these arrows and certain things
are going to happen and these things are
also going to be the product of many
generations they are not something that
happens all at once like language you
notice suddenly pops into everybody's
head and here is where Brousseau is
actually saying that a lot of his
predecessors have got things wrong
they're taking people that they assume
to be like this and they're you know
with all other capacities all the things
that took human beings thousands of
years to develop and they're projecting
them back into an original state of
human nature and saying that's what it
must have been like for it for human
beings so Thomas Hobbs for example comes
in for a lot of criticism as having
taken the you know human beings as we
know them in our society you know about
a hundred
and 50 odd years before maybe a little
bit less before so and having projected
them into a state without society we see
things sort of like this when we have
fantasy or science fiction novels or TV
shows where we throw a bunch of people
onto a desert island and there's no
society and they have to decide what
they're going to do we actually you know
have a whole show that was quite popular
for a while where they kind of did that
called survivor and Rousseau is saying
no in the original state human beings
are just like one step up from the other
animals as a matter of fact the only
ways that human beings other than that
you know the way their body is designed
are fundamentally differing from the
other animals are in the possession of
two different but interconnected
faculties that are going to be
absolutely determinative for them he
says animals think animals and human
beings are not radically distinct on
that basis they think we think as matter
of fact someone less may think less than
certain animals there's not a huge
difference how we differ is that we have
freewill
animals are stuck with their basic set
of instincts which are quite malleable
so consider a dog for example you know
dogs in their natural environment our
pack creatures they know how to find
food they know how to copulate and make
new doggies they know how to bark it a
things and chase them down and play with
each other and bite each other and fight
for dominance and all these sorts of
things but it's within a narrow range
and what the dog does is not the same
thing as what the cat does or what the
bear does so we may have scribe the same
sort of ideas and while the Bears are
fighting for dominance over territory or
something like that but it's really a
whole different set of instincts so each
animal each animal species is kind of
like its own you know world on to itself
in a way and they can't fundamentally
change
they're on nature so you know a dog is
not going to say I need to be a
vegetarian it's not it's not nice to eat
meat that'll never happen
nor does that gonna happen by the way
with a cat cats are even more vicious
than dogs in that respect that's part of
why I love about cats human beings on
the other hand have freewill
so human beings can actually go against
their instincts they can say no or they
can decide I'm gonna do this even though
my instinct is is telling me to go over
here and that can really screw us up as
a matter of fact that's not a
necessarily good thing according to
Rousseau it's it's a way in which we
manage to get ourselves and also the
difficulties the instinct might have
gotten us out of but it also opens up
the door for human beings to be able to
decide for themselves what it is that
they are going to do and what it is over
time that they are going to be and what
the people coming after them are gonna
have on the horizon to do and be as well
that brings us to the second key
difference between human beings and
animals and that is what Rousseau calls
the capacity or the Faculty of
self-improvement we are able to actually
work upon ourselves and make ourselves
more than we are more than we have been
and we have to do this of necessity
because the human animal unlike most
other animals doesn't have all of what
it needs from birth on you know if you
think about insects for example I
remember you know in the spring I would
watch and a praying mantises hatch and
you would see this entire like flood of
little tiny baby praying mantises that
look exactly like adult praying mantises
except very small just running and
running and running across you know the
earth and you you know why is there so
many of them cuz most of them are gonna
get eaten by stuff and then there'll be
a few praying mantises left but those
little tiny baby praying mantises they
have all the instincts of
adult praying mantis already hardwired
into their brains same thing goes for
spiders I remember you know in the
spring seeing little baby brown recluses
running all over the place in Indiana as
well because you know they'd hatched and
same thing with house spiders you can
see that happening little spiders are
just little spiders a dear about you
know an hour after it's born or even a
calf account a domesticated animal it's
ready to start walking around it's not
ready to start eating grass yet it's
gonna nurse for a while but it's not
going to nurse for that long the period
of development for most animals except
you know with certain things like you
know where there's larval stages and
pupae and then finally adults age it
tends to be pretty short n even those
animals that do have stages like that
you know a caterpillar starts out as an
egg and then it becomes a caterpillar
and it eats a lot of stuff and it forms
a cocoon or a pupa and then it becomes a
butterfly and never actually like you
know says I'm not gonna be a butterfly
the hell with that I'm gonna be a beetle
instead or I'm gonna have armor plating
or where I'm going to do that sort of
thing human beings we can in fact decide
to make more of ourselves and we have to
in part because of the kind of creatures
that we are we are infants for a while
who are totally helpless totally
vulnerable totally up to the mercy of
the environment and those who are
tending to us and then we become
children then we become an alliance then
we become adults and half the time as
adults we're still just big children
screwing things up and maybe by the time
that were 40 some most 50 some of the 60
we've got things figured out and we've
worked upon ourselves a lot of times so
these two things make us different from
the other animals those are what allow
us to develop thought and language those
also come out of having the passions and
at first they were so thanks human
beings are fundamentally you know trying
to respond to their emotions their
passions their
desires but through that comes the
development of thought and the
development of language and these two go
hand-in-hand with each other because you
need thought in order to continue to
develop language especially if you want
to have something like what we call
grammar grammar is necessary in order
for you to be able to understand what
I'm saying articulation on the other
hand language is needed in order for
thought to advance and along with these
comes the first beginnings of
Association of human beings through
natural sympathy with each other that
provides the basis for that and the
grouping of human beings into families
and for you know finding some sort of
fixed residence building shelters
staying into the same roof produces the
first property it also begins to affect
our passions as well we begin to feel
things we didn't feel before like say
conjugal love or but you know paternal
affection Rousseau says all of this is
going to lead us ultimately to a state
of he calls them you know savages or
barbarians but we could just think of
you know if you like the word primitive
peoples or indigenous hunter-gatherers
pastoralist people like that that's what
he has in mind as we begin to become
more settled something else comes in and
that's very important and that's this
conception of morality and that begins
to replace this primitive natural
sympathy that we have for others of our
own kind
this fellow feeling instead we begin to
be concerned with comparison of
ourselves with others and in in our
status and in not having our status
violated by other people when they do
violate our status if we can and we
punish them as hard as we can to make
sure that not only do they not do it and
we get something back but all those
other jerks over there don't think about
messing with my status and in the state
of savagery morality begins to take
control over
the human heart rather than than
sympathy now it's possible to stay in a
state like that where you now have
thought you know language you have
property of morality it's it's pretty
easy to to live you know human beings
have figured out some basic technology
they're able to provide themselves with
food they have some leisure time and
they enjoy themselves quite a bit and
it's actually pretty healthy bodily as
far as your soul is concerned the second
revolution he says the first revolution
is that of property the second
revolution is of agriculture and
metallurgy metallurgy might be thought
of as we call it a technological
revolution you know learning how to work
metal vastly expands the human
capacities to change their environment
to work upon the natural things that
they encounter to engage in agriculture
to better engage in hunting it also
raises the stakes for they're killing
each other as well you know stone knives
impo and stone bows and arrows and
spears not so much that you can do with
them compared to say a bronze sword or a
bronze axe and human beings are now
becoming a much more dominant force
within the entire eco sphere you can say
along what if this comes the development
of different forms of wealth more
development to the passions more
capacity for comparing ourselves against
other people and eventually this leads
us into the state of civilization and
civilization is is you know an ongoing
process for or so one of the key things
that happens with civilization is the
introduction of law and he talks about
this as a trick that the rich play upon
the poor the rich want everybody treated
equally
everybody protected by the law but what
that really means is the protection of
the property of the rich society society
what we're talking about there is a
whole
complex set of valuations of people
against people compared to each other
the notion that people have you know
certain customs that they have to follow
you were born into this class you should
stay in that class you should know your
place all of that is part of society as
he's talking about it and then finally
government government itself expands and
expands and expands and covers more and
more of human life and eventually what
we have is an entire set of inequalities
that didn't exist in these states back
here but do exist in the state of
civilization and these inequalities make
for a pretty unhappy life even for the
rich even for the powerful so you know
Rousseau thinks that the civilized
person is a sick person that the really
healthiest person is this one or at
least the people in these you know
indigenous primitive less less civilized
societies that is the grand sweep of his
argument so he's not saying that
civilization is in fact a good thing in
and of itself it does open up a lot of
possibilities for us this is something
that should pose some really interesting
questions for our thinking about how we
use technology ourselves and where our
civilization is going if you're sober
here in the present they might have
additional stages that he would have put
here but I think that his basic argument
would still be the same he'd be asking
us how did we get here does any of this
have a necessary basis the answer turns
out to be no and then what should we or
what can we do not only as individuals
which you know as individuals maybe we
can you know get ourselves back to land
or live in a commune or you know become
hunters and fishers or something like
that but what should we do or what can
we do as a society those are the sort of
questions that were left with at the end
of this